et elle se réfléchit contre les objets de leur environnement et revient en écho,
et les chauves-souris entendent alors ces échos
et elles transcrivent ces informations en une image acoustique.
Cela leur permet de s'orienter dans l'obscurité la plus totale.
En effet, elles ont un drôle d'air. Nous sommes des humains.
Nous sommes une espèce très portée sur le visuel. Quand les scientifiques ont réalisé pour la première fois
que les chauves-souris utilisaient le son pour pouvoir voler
et s'orienter et se déplacer la nuit, nous n'y croyions pas.
Pendant une centaine d'années, malgré les preuves qui montraient
que c'était ce qu'elles faisaient, nous n'y croyions pas.
Maintenant, si vous regardez cette chauve-souris, elle a un petit air d'extra-terrestre.
En effet, le très célèbre philosophe Thomas Nagel
a dit un jour : « Pour voir une véritable forme de vie étrangère
sur cette planète, vous devriez vous enfermer dans une pièce
avec une chauve-souris qui vole et utilise l'écholocation dans une obscurité complète. »
Et si vous faites attention aux caractéristiques physiques
de la tête de cette belle rhinolophe fer-à-cheval,
vous voyez que beaucoup de ces caractéristiques sont dédiées
à émettre du son et à le percevoir en retour.
De très grandes oreilles, d'étranges feuilles nasales, mais de tout petits yeux.
Encore une fois, rien qu'en regardant cette chauve-souris, vous réalisez
que le son est très important pour sa survie.
La majorité des chauves-souris ressemblent à cette dernière.
Cependant, il existe un groupe qui n'utilise pas l'écholocation.
Elles ne perçoivent pas leur environnement en utilisant le son,
et ce sont les renards volants.
Si quelqu'un a déjà eu la chance d'aller en Australie,
vous les avez vu sortir du Jardin Botanique de Sydney,
et rien qu'en regardant leur tête, vous pouvez voir
qu'ils sont de bien plus grands yeux et de plus petites oreilles.
Parmi les chauves-souris, il y a donc une grande variation
dans leur capacité à utiliser leurs perceptions sensorielles.
Cela va être important pour ce que je vais
vous raconter par la suite.
Si l'idée de chauves-souris dans les beffrois vous terrifie,
et je sais que certains d'entre vous se sentent probablement un peu mal
en regardant de très grandes images de chauves-souris,
ce n'est probablement pas tellement surprenant,
parce qu'ici dans la culture occidentale,
les chauves-souris ont été diabolisées.
Vraiment, bien sûr, le célèbre livre "Dracula",
écrit par Bram Stoker, un homme du nord de Dublin,
en est probablement le principal responsable.
Cependant, je pense que cela a également à voir
avec le fait qu'elles sortent la nuit, et que nous ne
les comprenons pas vraiment. Nous sommes un peu effrayés par les choses
qui peuvent percevoir le monde légèrement différemment de nous.
Les chauves-souris sont généralement associées à des évènements néfastes.
Elles sont les coupables dans les films d'horreur,
comme ce célèbre "Les ailes de la nuit."
Par ailleurs, si vous y réfléchissez, les démons
ont toujours des ailes de chauves-souris, alors que les oiseaux généralement --
ou les anges ont des ailes d'oiseaux.
Mais cela est le point de vue occidental, et ce que j'espère accomplir ce soir,
c'est vous convertir à la culture traditionnelle chinoise,
parce qu'ils voient les chauves-souris comme
des créatures qui portent chance, et en effet, si vous entrez
dans une maison chinoise, vous verrez peut-être une image comme celle-ci.
Ce sont les Cinq Bénédictions.
Le mot chinois pour "chauve-souris" ressemble au mot chinois
pour "bonheur", et ils croient que les chauves-souris
apportent richesse, santé, longévité, vertu et sérénité.
Et en effet, dans cette image, vous avez une représentation de la longévité
entourée de cinq chauves-souris.
Et ce que je veux faire ce soir, c'est vous parler
et vous montrer qu'au moins trois de ces bénédictions
sont certainement représentées par une chauve-souris, et que si nous étudions les chauves-souris,
nous nous rapprocherons de chacune de ces bénédictions.
La richesse -- Comment une chauve-souris peut-elle donc nous apporter la richesse ?
Comme je l'ai dit avant, les chauves-souris sont essentielles au bon fonctionnement
de nos écosytèmes. Et pourquoi donc ?
Les chauves-souris dans les tropiques sont des pollinisateurs majeurs pour beaucoup de plantes.
Elles se nourissent aussi de fruits, et elles dispersent les graines
de ces fruits. Les chauves-souris sont responsables de la pollinisation
de la plante de la tequila, et c'est une industrie qui pèse plusieurs millions de dollars
au Mexique. Donc en effet, nous avons besoin d'elles
pour que nos écosystèmes fonctionnent correctement.
Sans elles, il y aurait un problème.
Mais la plupart des chauves-souris sont des prédateurs voraces d'insectes.
Aux Etat-Unis, on a estimé, dans une toute petite colonie
de grosses chauves-souris brunes, qu'elles se nourrissent de
plus d'un million d'insectes par an,
et aux Etats-Unis, en ce moment,
les chauves-souris sont menacées par une maladie connue sous le nom de syndrome du nez blanc.
Elle se propage lentement à travers les Etats-Unis et décime
des populations de chauves-souris, et les scientifiques ont estimé
que maintenant 1 300 tonnes d'insectes par an
restent dans notre écosystème à cause de la disparition des chauves-souris.
Les chauves-souris sont aussi menacées aux Etats-Unis
à cause de leur attirance pour les fermes éoliennes. Encore une fois, en ce moment même
les chauves-souris se trouvent face à un problème.
Elles vont être -- Elles sont très menacées
rien qu'aux Etats-Unis.
Comment cela peut-il nous aider ?
Nous avons calculé que si nous devions retirer les chauves-souris
de l'équation, nous allons alors devoir utiliser
des insecticides pour supprimer tous ces insectes nuisibles
qui se nourrissent de nos récoltes agricoles.
Et pour un an rien qu'aux Etats-Unis, on estime
que cela va coûter 22 milliards de dollars,
si nous supprimons les chauves-souris. Donc en effet, les chauves-souris nous apportent la richesse.
Elles maintiennent la santé de nos écosystèmes,
et nous permettent aussi d'économiser de l'argent.
Encore une fois, voilà la première bénédiction. Les chauves-souris sont importantes
pour nos écosystèmes.
Et qu'en est-il de la seconde ? Qu'en est-il de la santé ?
Dans chaque cellule de votre corps, il y a votre génome.
Votre génome est fait de votre ADN,
votre ADN code des protéines qui vous permettent de fonctionner
et d'intéragir et d'être comme vous êtes.
Avec les nouvelles avancées dans les technologies moléculaires modernes,
il nous est désormais possible de séquencer notre propre génome
dans un temps très court et à un coût très, très réduit.
Quand nous avons fait ceci, nous avons réalisé
qu'il existe des variations dans notre génome.
Je veux que vous regardiez la personne à côté de vous.
Juste un coup d'oeil. Ce que nous devons réaliser
c'est que chacune des 300 paires de base de votre ADN, vous êtes un peu différent.
Un des grands défis désormais
en médecine moléculaire moderne est de déterminer
si cette variation vous rend plus fragiles face aux maladies,
ou si cette variation vous rend simplement différent ?
Encore une fois, qu'est-ce que cela veut dire ? Qu'est-ce que cette variation
signifie vraiment ? Si nous tirons partie de toutes ces
nouvelles données moléculaires et de ces informations personnalisées sur le génome
qui arrivent sur la toile et que nous pourrons avoir
dans les années à venir, nous devons être capables de différencier
les deux. Comment faire ?
Je suggère que nous regardions les expériences de la nature.
A travers la sélection naturelle, dans le temps,
les mutations et les variations qui modifient la fonction d'une protéine
ne seront pas tolérées sur le long terme.
L'évolution agit comme un tamis. Elle trie les mauvaises variations.
En conséquence, si vous regardez la même partie
d'un génome chez beaucoup de mammifères qui ont
évolué en s'éloignant les uns des autres
et qui sont également écologiquement divergents, vous aurez une meilleure
compréhension de l'évolution précédente de cette partie.
Par exemple, si cette partie du génome est importante pour le mammifère,
pour sa survie, elle sera la même
dans tous ces différents lignages, espèces, taxons .
Par conséquent, si nous faisions cela,
nous devrions séquencer cette partie
chez tous ces différents mammifères, et confirmer si c'est la même
ou non. Si c'est la même,
cela indique que cette partie du génome est importante pour une fonction du mammifère,
donc une mutation menant à une maladie devrait s'inscrire dans cette partie.
Dans ce cas précis, si tous les mammifères que nous étudions
ont un génome de type « jaune » sur cette partie,
cela suggère probablement que le « violet » est mauvais.
Cela pourrait être encore plus puissant si vous regardez des mammifères
qui font les choses légèrement différemment.
Disons, par exemple, que la région du génome
que j'étais en train de regarder était une région qui est importante pour la vision.
Si nous regardons cette région chez les mammifères qui n'ont pas une bonne vue,
comme les chauves-souris, et que nous découvrons que les chauves-souris qui ne voient pas bien
ont le type « violet », nous savons que c'est probablement
ce qui cause cette maladie.
Dans mon laboratoire, nous avons utilisé des chauves-souris pour étudier deux types
différents de maladies des sens.
Nous étudions la cécité. Pour quelle raison ?
Trois cent quatorze millions de personnes sont malvoyantes, et
parmi celles-ci 45 millions sont aveugles. Donc la cécité est un gros problème,
et beaucoup de ces problèmes de vue viennent de maladies héréditaires,
donc nous voulons essayer de mieux comprendre
quelles mutations des gènes causent ces maladies.
Nous étudions aussi la surdité. Un nouveau-né sur 1 000
est sourd, et quand nous atteignons 80 ans,
plus de la moitié d'entre nous aurons aussi des problèmes d'audition.
Encore une fois, il existe de nombreuses causes génétiques qui expliquent cela.
Dans mon laboratoire
nous étudions ces spécialistes uniques des facultés sensorielles, les chauves-souris,
et nous avons étudié les gènes qui causent la cécité
quand ils présentent un défaut,
et les gènes qui causent la surdité quand ils présentent un défaut,
et nous sommes désormais en mesure de prédire quelles parties sont les plus susceptibles de causer des maladies.
Donc les chauves-souris sont aussi importantes pour notre santé,
pour nous permettre de mieux comprendre comment notre génome fonctionne.
Voilà où nous en sommes aujourd'hui,
mais qu'en est-il de l'avenir ?
Qu'en est-il de la longévité ?
Voilà ce vers quoi nous nous dirigeons, et comme je l'ai dit avant,
je crois sincèrement que le secret de l'éternelle jeunesse
se trouve dans le génome de la chauve-souris.
Pourquoi nous intéresser au processus du vieillissement ?
Eh bien, voilà un croquis du 16ème siècle
de la Fontaine de Jouvance. Le vieillissement est
un des aspects les plus familiers, néanmoins un des moins bien compris
de la biologie, et vraiment,
depuis l'aube de la civilisation, l'Homme a cherché à éviter ce phénomène.
Mais nous allons devoir le comprendre un peu mieux.
Rien qu'en Europe, d'ici 2050, il va y avoir
une hausse de 70% de la population de plus de 65 ans,
et une hausse de 170% de la population de plus de 80 ans.
Tandis que nous vieillissons, nous nous déteriorons, et cette déterioration
est source de problèmes pour notre société, et donc nous devons trouver des solutions.
Comment le secret de la jeunesse éternelle pourrait-il résider
dans le génome de la chauve-souris ? Est-ce que quelqu'un
veut deviner quelle est l'espérance de vie de cette chauve-souris ?
Qui -- levez la main -- qui dit deux ans ?
Personne ? Une ? Et dix ans ?
Quelques uns ? Et trente ans ?
Et 40 ? Okay, on a des réponses très différentes.
Cette chauve-souris est la myotis brandtii. C'est la chauve-souris qui vit le plus longtemps.
Elle a vécu jusqu'à 42 ans,
et cette chauve-souris est toujours vivante dans la nature aujourd'hui.
Mais qu'est-ce que cela a d'incroyable ?
Généralement, chez les mammifères il y a une relation
entre la taille du corps, le métabolisme,
et la durée de vie, et vous pouvez prédire
combien de temps un mammifère peut vivre, en fonction de sa taille.
Donc généralement, les petits mammifères vivent vite, et meurent jeunes.
Prenez une souris par exemple. Mais les chauves-souris sont très différentes.
Comme vous pouvez le voir sur ce graphique, en bleu,
ce sont tous les autres mammifères, mais les chauves-souris
peuvent vivre jusqu'à 9 fois plus longtemps que prévu
malgré leur métabolisme vraiment très rapide,
et la question se pose : comment est-ce possible ?
Il existe 19 espèces de mammifères qui vivent plus longtemps
que prévu, en fonction de leur taille, que l'homme,
et 18 d'entre elles sont des chauves-souris.
Par conséquent, il doit y avoir quelque chose dans leur ADN
qui leur permet de gérer le stress métabolique,
en particulier quand elles volent. Elles dépensent 3 fois plus d'énergie
qu'un mammifère de la même taille,
mais elle ne semblent pas en subir les conséquences ni les effets.
En ce moment, dans mon laboratoire, nous combinons
la biologie de terrain de pointe sur les chauves-souris, en allant attraper
les chauves-souris qui vivent longtemps, avec les technologies
moléculaires modernes dernier cri, afin de mieux comprendre
ce qu'elles font pour arrêter de vieillir comme nous.
Avec un peu de chance, dans les 5 ans à venir, je ferai une conférence TED à ce sujet.
Le vieillissement est un gros problème pour l'humanité,
et je crois qu'en étudiant les chauves-souris, nous pourrons découvrir
les mécanismes moléculaires qui permettent aux mammifères
d'avoir une longévité extraordinaire. Si nous trouvons
ce qu'ils font, peut-être pourrons-nous faire la même chose
via une thérapie génique.
Potentiellement, cela signifie que nous pourrions arrêter de vieillir ou même peut-être inverser le processus.
Imaginez cela un instant.
Donc vraiment, je ne crois pas que nous devrions les percevoir comme
des démons volants de la nuit, mais plus comme nos super-héros.
Et la réalité est que les chauves-souris peuvent nous apporter tellement de bonnes choses
si on sait où regarder. Elles sont bonnes pour notre écosystème,
elles nous permettent de comprendre comment notre génome fonctionne,
et elles détiennent potentiellement le secret de l'éternelle jeunesse.
Donc ce soir, quand vous sortirez d'ici et que vous lèverez les yeux
vers le ciel nocturne, et que vous verrez ce beau mammifère volant,
je veux que vous souriiez. Merci. (Applaudissements).